Once Upon hey guys I'm Tiffany outward
and I am a singer songwriter I loved
first covers and original songs on
YouTube and singing is my passion I have
a web series on Austin is TV it's called
Tiffany take over and what it is is
awesomeness TV actually came and
followed me out to Ohio where I shot
most of my music videos for my new album
called my heart is and so they got
behind the scenes exclusive you know
everything that went on into making the
music videos and so they put all that
together for Tiffany to go right I think
it's really awesome to be able to let
other people you know see what goes on
behind the scenes and to give them like
an inside scoop on to how it's all done
and you know some of the funny things
that happen as well as you know the more
serious moments like I think it really
gives opens people's eyes to see how
much work goes into it so I I think it's
really awesome to give them like a
real-life you what's happening I started
writing songs when I was 10 and I'd
always loved music and when I was about
15 I found YouTube and I saw other
people singing on youtube and is like oh
that's so cool like they were reaching
their dreams and you know they had music
videos or were on the radio and it was
because of YouTube so I was like that is
so cool like I would love to share my
music and you know get my music out
there so one day I was like well you
know I might as well give it a shot see
what people think and so it's kind of
just oh you know maybe get some feedback
never really expecting anything so it's
really awesome how how much the internet
it can change everything without YouTube
there is no doubt in my mind that I
would not have that popularity
it's slowly you know i posted my first
video and probably like three weeks
later I I was excited to have like 300
views like that was a lot for me and so
to see where I've come to now is just
mind-blowing like I still don't feel
like it's real it's like wait what
really like that's crazy and so there's
no way it would happen without YouTube
and I think just you know being genuine
or you know always being yourself people
can see that and they either like it or
they don't I guess in the next few
months I'm going to be doing a lot of
touring i'm actually going on tour with
all-star weekend starting January
nineteenth through februari 22nd and so
I'm really really excited because I'm
going to be able to finally get to meet
a lot of my fans and I love getting able
to like see them face to face and it
like makes it real and you know just
posting more my music videos and all
that fun stuff so that's what I'm gonna
be up to and also if anyone is
interested in seeing what's up or what
I'm doing they can find out my facebook
at facebook.com/ such took me out word
so everything that I'm doing movie
yesterday once upon a time go I wore a
pretty dress and you put